when you first came out man i remember
being like yo this dude was
like hearing your early [ __ ] like i
remember finding you on two dope boys
early on
and uh and um
that was what you were known for and
then ladies discovered you and now
to change the game plan and now and now
well now you're
you know shout out to all the women that
are all of a sudden listening to some
like
some davey [ __ ] that they would have
never have listened to before in their
entire [ __ ] life
but because you're dave easton you're
their man crush monday
um you're bringing them into that world
like what did
do you remember when you noticed like
you be you were becoming like a thing
with the
with the women oh yeah i mean uh after
um
perfect the chris brown [ __ ] i did when
i first linked with chris brown
and that went like public it's
everything it was over it changed stuff
for me
it changed everything ig [ __ ] everything
everything
it switched up not that it was bad
before but you know
after after you got a record with breezy
it might change up for you would you say
that i think
most of the people who are fans of your
music
right are probably like me or you know
homies right because the kind of [ __ ]
you make
right but would you say your fan base as
a whole
now probably encompasses more women than
anything yeah
i feel like coming in like you said it
was more
uh you were like a breath of fresh air
to hip-hop hip-hop
people that loves lyricism like that
crowd 100
then it transitioned into the girls and
then i started doing the acting
so i feel like a lot of my fan base is
um
i feel like a lot of my fan base might
not even know my music or know what
that's what i was gonna have
yeah i think i feel like some people
just follow you because it's just low
key they're they're just trying to like
you know what come on i'm saying if it
don't hurt it don't hurt me at all
no i mean and obviously i'm sure it
hey you'll take any following you can
get man especially in 2020